hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today in my kitchen we are making a
rainbow cake this has been such a highly
requested video I think ever since I
started first making baking videos
probably like four or five years ago so
finally today this is the cake that we
are going to make and this isn't just
any cake this icon is in the game cookie
jam blast so do you guys have ever
played cookie jam this is the newest
game in their franchise if you guys
liked cookie jam then you're going to
absolutely love cookie jam blonde you go
to the game and you match each of the
candy pieces so they're all color
coordinated so I've got to get this red
heart into here so that I can show you
guys the cake which I think this is it
okay here we go so as soon as I move
this heart up you can hear the close-up
picture of the cake that we're making
this game is free-to-play it's available
on iOS and the Google Play Store so when
you switch pieces with a rainbow cake it
will remove all of those colors from the
board pretty much one of the most iconic
icons in the game what I love most about
this cake is it has chocolate icing most
of the rainbow cakes that I've seen
online they all have vanilla a cookie
dish it's so cute these types of games
are my week-long boom now I have
everything prepped and ready and in
front of me and just like magic this is
the icon and I've got this all printed
out so that I can know what colors I
need to make so we're going to do is
we're going to make three cakes and I'm
not sure if I can fit three cakes inside
of this mixer but you better believe
we're going to try it
this is a very bad idea I can already
tell this is not going to be the best
thing that I've ever done one and a half
cups of oil and eight eggs oh gosh
[Music]
joke are we gonna be able I don't know
look it out oh I'm gonna get it get it
this is where it's going to get a little
iffy oh my gosh
I haven't even put the oil in yet wait
wait wait wait wait
I have them I have something this will
alleviate snes's oh my god this is
perfect
can you see what I've got here I dumped
it in and it goes right in that's a lot
of oil all right well it's and it's all
in now what happens if we go a little
bit faster
I'm so nervous this is gonna go crazy
but I think it's okay if you asked me if
this is going to actually work I would
have said nope I too much cake Oh oh my
gosh this is ridiculously heavy so we're
going to start with all of our color
dyes here and all of our holes so what
we're going to do is we're going to
portion out all of this batter into each
one of these little bowls and then we're
going to dive
[Music]
whoa I got that everywhere and now we
only have one more to go
the purple next step is to get all of
your pans I'm using these little
circular ones don't forget to spray them
because if you do forget to spray you're
going to be really sorry later
[Music]
[Applause]
and I thought to give you a simple plus
three I'm going to try to make three
same time so I'm not sure how that's
going to work out but I don't want to be
a bacon cake all day long let's put
three in and then when those are done
I'll bake the other three without
chocolate icing and of course I'm not
going to make the icing myself so
wonderful store-bought icing and we're
going to need a lot of icing because
each layer has chocolate inside of it
doesn't have to probably do a taste test
because you know I just want to make
sure that it's satisfactory
oh there's only 130 calories and kanpur
14 servings
well that just ruined everything I
planned on eating the whole container
let's boost it up to 11 whoa whoa whoa
now watch me mix now watch me nae nae
this is just what we were looking for I
think that's good
okay so the first color we're gonna need
is our purple cake and all of our cakes
are looking so beautiful let me show
them to you we're just going to shave it
down so that the top of it'll be nice
and level look how beautiful and purple
this look can you even flop this bad boy
right onto here and this is the start of
a beautiful beautiful creation I'm
pretty problem really this is already
looking pretty good
[Music]
so this is our last layer the red layer
is the top layer because all life so
much I guess this ain't cleaned up and
we'll do our final presentation and
taste test it way looks like 700
[Music]
different ages six different layers and
four containers of icing you ready
look at that I am blown away with how
incredible this look look like oh are
you ready to watch me do this yes you do
this yourself I'll believe it when I
watch the tape I kind of like the icing
is back oh my gosh but look how pretty
it is Oh what oh no oh no what
this is really good what are you sitting
on here
definitely the most effort I put into a
cake yeah I had to wait so long for her
to finish this cake thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this video I had so much fun making this
and I'm so surprised that it actually
turned out absolutely incredible it
turned out way better than I thought it
was going to make sure you guys check
out the link in description if you want
to check out cookie jam blast and I will
see you guys in my next video also leave
me some comments on what you'd like to
see me make next because this again has
been such a highly requested video thank
you guys for the inspiration
see you later I can go eat this piece at
a private
[Music]